la cathédrale st volodymyr et le centre
ville de kiev sont habituellement très
fréquenté et là vous pouvez le voir il
n'y a quasiment personne était encore
plus calme ce matin toute la journée des
sirènes ont retenti pour donner l'ordre
aux gens d'aller s'abriter d'aller se
réfugier alors que des bombardements
russes avaient lieu ici à kiev les
soldats russes sont arrivés notamment
dans le quartier d'obo launsky que
certains considèrent comme un quartier à
part entière de kiev il y a eu des
échanges de tirs nourris et aussi des
affrontements avec les troupes
ukrainienne et donc la crainte ici est
très forte de voir des troupes russes
arrivés en nombre il y a eu des
hélicoptères qui sont arrivés un
déposant des troupes semble-t-il aux
alentours de kiev dans les banlieues on
a entendu de nombreuses détonations
toute la journée et je peux vous dire
qu'ici il y a une certaine inquiétude de
voir les troupes russes arrivés à les
autorités ukrainiennes à 10 a demandé
aux gens de prendre les armes ce qu'ils
le peuvent les réservistes sont déjà
mobilisés et le ministère de la défense
ukrainien demande aux ukrainiens ici à
kiev de créer des cocktails molotov et
de prendre les armes au cas où les au
cas où les russes arrivent vous pouvez
l'entendre une nouvelle sirène retentit
pour demander aux ukrainiens à d'aller
prendre refuge dans un des abris sous
les bâtiments ou dans le métro au cas où
des missiles pourraient arriver ici
selon certains témoignages à des milles
s'ils seraient arrivés tout près du
ministère de la défense qui est à
seulement un kilomètre 5 d'où je me
trouve
[Musique]